why would someone
risk it all for the game they love this
is this is
unprecedented his he's so solid
with such a weird character the
character is like the opposite of salt
oh yeah why would someone play a
character that everyone else has written
off when they're trying to become the
best player in the world
i just thought of something what's that
what if the bear becomes our global
champion
and what would compel someone to travel
the world grinding the
hardest fighting game out there all for
a meager 7
500 grand prize rocks dragon's knee he's
gonna have to fight
against this new upstart this guy that
just started traveling yeah first on
esports wrong
tekken is the most exciting fighting
game in the world right now
and for roncho the rookie who did all
that it's his
life make some noise
tekken is a game dominated by its old
guard it's a storied scene with a legacy
of incredible players
guys like jdcr knee kudon saint have
been playing the series for
years
rongchu wasn't one of those household
names in fact he was basically a nobody
before 2018.
rocks dragon's knee he's gonna have to
fight against this new upstart this guy
that just started traveling
yeah first on esports wrong he played
his first tournament in korea in 2015.
inspired to pick up the game after
watching korea's televised tekken crash
tournament
and watching the pros make the game look
incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
being a new player is hard enough but
starting fresh in tekken is harder than
in any other
game see the top players have been
playing for years
and that means a lot more in tekken than
anywhere else me
looking very dominant in this matchup
unlike what we've seen before
wow he's up two rounds against rancho
i feel like yeah i feel v was like just
you know oh you can't wait
part of the reason is tekken doesn't
really change you know like
the core tech and gameplay has been the
same since tekken 5.
if anything the game has been simplified
right so anyone who had legacy skill who
had trained at some point long enough
hard enough to compete at the highest
level
those skills are going to carry over and
on top of that tekken is
[ __ ] hard each character has
somewhere around 100 potential attacks
to use in a match
and the 3d battle system is pretty
difficult to pick up for people coming
from 2d games like street fighter or
marvel vs capcom
when you go back to like something like
street fighter you know like okay i can
do a ling combo here because i'm plus
three here and i have a three frame jab
etc right in tech and you're like i got
him in the air
i can do whatever move i want you know
you have a roster like 100 moves in your
move list
being like all right i'm going to try
this one that one there extend the combo
with this move and then get to combos
there's a basic combo structure but
it's totally free form and how you want
to use it oh my god oh
my god basically it's gonna be hard for
any aspiring tekken pro but
rongchu persevered and to get better he
trained at green arcade
tekken is the most popular fighting game
in korea home to some of the best
players in the world there was a
location test at a place known as green
arcade
one of the tekken capitals of the world
green arcade was tekken's
mecca before it closed in 2018 it was
the place where champions were
forged green arcade is often packed and
is decorated with the accolades and
trophies won by the players that go
there
i noticed they even had knees evo 2013
trophy for tekken tag 2.
all of korea's greatest tekken players
went there to learn train and just catch
a few games after school or work
the etiquette to getting the next game
is putting coins on the machine not to
unlike the us
but they might not get up right away if
they're in the middle of a special
revenge match to maintain their rank
but rongchu still in high school at the
time had to work hard
to get the pro's attention so he studied
a move list instead of schoolwork and
kept coming back to green arcade get his
[ __ ] kicked in by the best players in
the world
i went to green arcade like in 2010
around 2011
and i was getting beat up by little
literally middle schoolers it might have
been wrong too
beating me up in the arcade back then uh
so yeah it's it's an experience that you
cannot get anywhere
really sad that arcade is gone
eventually rangsi began to grind the
tournament circuit but to make his life
even harder he didn't pick a top tier
character like devil jin or xiaoyu
he played panda panda
lily
[Music]
panda rongsu didn't play panda because
she was some secret top tier pick though
no panda is a giant slow target in the
game all about speed and grace
instead he picked her because like you
and me there are some things that ramshu
just isn't very good at
taking christianity
you know
by the time he could finally travel to
international tournaments in 2018
guys give it up for getting fourth place
here in poland thank you so much for
coming down
wow burusson rancho
first time out of asia and what's a
performance from him he took fifth six
as a tekken world tour korean masters
then fourth at fighting games challenge
in poland and in taiwan
he made it all the way to second place
unfortunately for wrong there were two
guys he could never quite beat
the only problem he's really had
throughout the entire tour was knee and
kudon's right
those are two guys that always gave him
issues kudos and me stood in rongsu's
way
time and time again beating him at abu
get cups
never mind evo 2018
he killed him very nice did you see that
little
timing stutter yeah at the end and rev
major
oh man and there it is again look at the
crowd that's how i'm feeling too
everyone with their hands on their head
they're like what the hell happened
there at the end and though roncho kept
pushing
those losses took their toll and made
him question his character choice
throughout the year i've seen him switch
characters i've seen him try out like
geese howard or something against the
end it always bothered me i was like
why aren't you just using the panda like
clearly your panda is good enough to get
you to this level
why do you not believe in it wrong shoe
kept bringing out other characters at
tournaments
stronger characters on paper to try to
defeat his demons
i didn't even notice drunk shoes picked
chosen
did you just see me blink i would be
like uh excuse me but it was panda that
worked
every tournament wrong she played well
at panda was the one that got him that
far
so when the world tour finals came
around rongchu played
panda and he toppled his group set him
up
and ran you two o's chanel oh there he
goes he hit
that one it doesn't find the rage driver
that will do it wrong
over for soraku now 2-0 here in group a
[Music]
ah very nice work pulls through
and rocky gets his first loss here in
the group stage
4-2-2-1 to punish and that will be that
rank 2 moves on over anakin raising his
arms in victory there solid
dominant performance only to face off
against one of his demons in the first
round of the bracket
knee oh yeah and i hope you guys are
ready for this so number one in points
throughout the second world tour season
mr rock's gaming
knee out of south korea gets rancho once
again
wrong two doubted himself wow picking
geese against uh
devil gin here okay okay here we go game
one
so we are uh we are not going to see the
bear here from uh person wrong
oh yes interesting choice and instead of
playing panda
he brought out geese and fang look at
this
exactly unprecedented pick it didn't
work
not only is this impressive just for the
sake of this match right now but you
know everyone else in this top eight is
watching this right oh man he's working
that rage right now
okay careful oh man just not
allowing the comeback there was hope for
a moment but need
such an unstoppable force nothing
personal just incredible
down in losers wrong shoe had already
proven more than enough
he's figured out how to make bears work
in a tournament setting oh man
that definitely he had proven that the
new generation of tekken talent was
worth taking just as seriously as the
old guard
he had proven that panda was stronger
than most people thought
oh my gosh here we go wrong to putting
on a clinic here
he had proven that he had what it takes
to stand alongside those players he saw
on tv
all those years ago this is this is
unprecedented his
he's so solid with such a
weird character the character's like the
opposite of salt oh yeah but that didn't
mean it was time for him to give up
oh man here we go as well that's going
to be it
celebration after dispatching john ding
and chanel
rongshu found himself face to face with
me once again so this is our losers
finals match which means
from here on out all the sets are gonna
be three out of five but this time
he went panda all the way okay so here
we go
oh and and he went with it he finally
picked the panda but yeah you know what
and knee is picking double j yes let's
see what the
character can bring to the table here
we've seen such solid game play out of
rank 2
using this weird obscure character at
such a high level
wow oh my gosh there's a jungle uppercut
this is big
delays the second hit oh nice he was
able to attack
their job using that stance wow that was
sick
yeah he's gonna clutch it out and that's
gonna be it wrong
right now the most impressive we've seen
so far him against me
oh oh wrong really are you gonna tie it
up like this
wow the dashing forward in bear stance
is so intimidating
careful all two hits again oh
what a block on the hell we've ranked
you
i just thought of something what's that
what if a bear becomes our global
champion
the wall pressure and another clutch
block on the hell sweep
chopping cabbage nice work oh my gosh
it's looking really good but what a
block there from neat
yes man rank two
he's gonna be in grand finals that's
crazy
okay okay be cool oh my gosh economy
finally let it loose there gets the bear
uppercut yeah the follow-up he has big
wall damage here
ouch other side this is like
top tier versus bottom tier right yeah
close without a doubt
yeah amazing bear wrong
one crazy match away yes and knee
considering what he needs to do here
processing what he's seen before his eye
he is sticking to devil jim
does not compute does not compute what's
going on here
bear against devil jim it makes no sense
chopping cabbage messes in for you oh
unfortunate there oh oh my god he's
gonna have to be careful
oh my god huge yeah huge cojones wow
ducking there oh man you gotta have
balls nice
dude i have not seen how limber this
panda
is exactly right being able to move and
outmaneuver devilgen at this point
oh my gosh did you see that sidestep
what an amazing twin piston punish there
rancho is such an impressive player dude
this is amazing hello
oh seven seconds left on the clock can
he kill
huge mistake should not have played so
many characters perhaps
wow amazing
incredible with one demon down there was
only one person left standing in wrong
chu's way
coudons yeah and here we go we got both
players up on the stage now
and it's gonna come down to this the
crowd obviously cheering them on
oh man i don't know i don't know who to
cheer for man this is nuts
but this time roncho and panda stole the
show
oh my god wow rang chu you know that
that was a good
opportunity you know kudos thought he
was gonna stay on the ground goes for
the laser but the wake up able to get
the launch
the aerial stake that would have been
ugly
wow wow yes two rounds straight here for
rank two coming out of losers bracket
is that a panda grand finals i think it
is oh my gosh what are we doing yeah
both players are well within kill range
exactly oh no he drops it
citrus fruit citrus fruit
oh wow and look at that little mini
pop-up
you know in the history of tekken there
has never
been a bear champion bear stance again
is that going to hit yes it is
i don't think it's going to kill is it
the laser oh
here we go but that thing is the oh my
god did you see that god slo-mo
rang chu is on the cusp of resetting the
bracket here
and he just did one shoots up the first
set
three to one resetting the bracket and
setting up the final showdown
coupons i think had prepared all year
long to beat
knee he wasn't preparing for his wrong
he's thinking i'm gonna play knee again
i'm ready this time all year long he's
been beating me with this lily and
whatever other garbage
but now i'm prepared for them i'm gonna
take him out and be the champion back to
back
and so when rancho beat me i'm like i
think kudos is in big trouble here
oh god oh good block no tsunami kick
punish
oh rank two pulling ahead
in the set after the reset taking
game one the crowd loves seeing the bear
wins
oh this is huge yes
he's gonna get to wake up and the wall
my god
oh oh man
oh this momentum is starting to shift i
can feel it
definitely rancho is feeling good right
now he's feeling great
two more rounds what's he gonna do
running bear attack into the mix-up
okay one more hit and he's one
round away life left
oh it's guaranteed last hit
bear champion oh he got him it's not
over
15 seconds oh he hit heaven's gate the
other side
be careful if one more he could hang in
here cue dance
we have a animal of a champion here
after all was said and done coudons and
his devil gin fell
three to one in the first set and three
to one again after the bracket reset
man congratulations i gotta give it up
wow
amazing work by furson rang chu
see rongchu ran a gauntlet not just at
the world finals but
all year long he attended event after
event all for a crack at the world title
at a tournament his parents didn't even
know he was at
i mean no one would have guessed that he
would be able to pull through here
with that character against these
opponents he already snatched his trophy
yeah man give me that [ __ ] beautiful
work
but his reward didn't reflect that he
lifted that trophy and got just seven
thousand five hundred dollars panda
panda
[Applause]
now everyone knew that going in and
fighting game prize pools have never
been the highest
but that prize pool is still pretty
rough just a few weeks after wrongchu's
win gachikun won capcom cup and took
home a quarter of a million dollars
now most of these guys aren't in it for
the money fighting game prize pools
usually aren't enough to live off of
but that money could help grow the scene
rongchu is a shining example of what new
blood can do for a scene
he flipped the tier lists beat some of
the best players in the world and
cemented his name in history
all after just one year of pro play and
there's no denying that a higher prize
pool can draw in new players who could
grow the game just like he has
but now it's up to namco bandai if they
can finally increase the prize pool
they could secure tekken's legacy for
years to come
make some noise for rank two
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button